este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a su
uso luego os doy más detalles pero antes
vamos a hablar de la otra guerra que
asoló europa antes de la guerra de
ucrania un conflicto que ocurrió cuando
muchos de vosotros todavía ibais a la
guardería hablamos de la guerra de los
balcanes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
serbia sólo salen las noticias cuando
defiende a novak djokovic el tenista que
por lo visto no quiere vacunarse ahora
bien a quién le importa serbia pueden ir
más de ajos a vladimir putin recordáis
el discurso en el que anunciaba la
invasión de ucrania seguro que todos
habéis visto en algún momento algún
extracto de ese discurso pues atentos a
esta parte pero ambientes ya que están
se sabe que esta página es que un
prevenir creó para el bayern o de herat
un proyecto grande después de hallar
sobre quite creamos tramo entre grupo
y
ayer una mujer aun
infrastructure aquí podéis ver como
putin recitaba todos los supuestos
agravios que occidente ha hecho contra
los intereses de rusia desde la
desintegración de la unión soviética en
esas estaba cuando el presidente ruso
mencionó los bombardeos de belgrado ella
se lo que estáis pensando mucho sobre
todo los que tengáis más de 30 años un
bar de os de belgrado eso me suena algo
yo de hablar de eso exacto hablamos de
un episodio de la guerra de los balcanes
uno de los conflictos más sanguinarios
de la historia moderna una guerra que se
produjo en suelo europeo cuando casi
todos los que veis visual político ya
habíais nacido hoy en día serbia es un
país con menos de 7 millones de
habitantes nunca ha sido una
superpotencia ni tiene recursos
naturales importantes sin embargo es en
este país donde estalló la primera
guerra mundial y la guerra de los
balcanes así que la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es por qué servía es tan
conflictiva que pasó exactamente en esa
famosa guerra de los balcanes que todos
vimos de pequeños en los telediarios y
lo que es más importante porque putin lo
recuerda en su discurso y en lazos
exactamente entre serbia y rusia hoy en
visual político vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes
hablando de guerras vamos a hablar de
cómo evitar que ataquen vuestro teléfono
móvil o vuestro ordenador en internet no
hay misiles pero hay otra cosa también
muy peligrosa hackers y ataques
cibernéticos cómo podemos protegernos
pues una muy buena forma de evitar buena
parte de estos hackers es utilizando una
vpn y cuál es la vpn favorita de visual
político exacto sur shark vpn y creedme
el tema de la ciberseguridad se lo toma
muy en serio por ejemplo su shark tiene
una herramienta que se llama clean web
que bloquea todos esos popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de votos y de cookies que francamente no
queremos tener pues si todo eso fuera
poco con una única cuenta de surf vp n
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos
que quieras quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu smart view o desde tu
teléfono móvil o desde tu ordenador pues
puedes hacer todo eso con una única
cuenta de surf shark vpn y por supuesto
tenemos una oferta muy especial para
todos vosotros que seguís uso político
básicamente si utilizáis el código
político terminado en casa podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento tres
meses extra totalmente gratuitos
encontrareis todos los enlaces en la
descripción no esperéis más y
descargaros ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
yugoslavia la tierra de los eslavos del
sur
durante siglos los balcanes fueron la
frontera entre dos imperios el austriaco
y el otomano fue a finales del siglo 19
cuando los serbios se independizaron del
dominio turco y proclamaron el reino de
serbia el problema el problema es que
los balcanes son el hogar de muchas
etnias distintas cada una con su idioma
su religión y su sentimiento nacional
algunos serbios no vivían dentro de este
nuevo reino de serbia muchos vivían en
bosnia herzegovina que era una provincia
dentro del imperio austrohúngaro pues
bien un grupo de separatistas serbios
organizaron el atentado de sarajevo el
resto es historia
en 1914 gavrilo princip un nacionalista
serbio asesinó al archiduque francisco
fernando heredero al trono del imperio
austrohúngaro
en consecuencia austria hungría declaró
la guerra al reino de serbia poniendo en
marcha todas las alianzas militares que
venían tejiéndose en europa en las
últimas décadas de hecho la propia rusia
se ve arrastrada al conflicto a raíz de
su pacto con serbia acababa de comenzar
en sarajevo la primera guerra mundial
serbia estuvo del lado de los vencedores
en la gran guerra y esto supuso que el
rey no ampliará considerablemente sus
territorios por fin era realidad una
yugoslavia independiente un país que
aglutinaría a los isla bosch del sur el
problema de nuevo que los eslavos del
sur estaban divididos en un montón de
etnias distintas y no todos tenían claro
que quisieran pertenecer a un mismo
estado
de hecho durante la segunda guerra
mundial los croatas apoyaron a hitler
para poder crear su propia croata
independiente y así es como surgió uno
de los regímenes más sanguinarios de la
historia la gusta su paréntesis no voy a
entrar en detalles pero los tasa fue tan
brutal que incluso los nazis llegaron a
juzgar algunos de sus altos mandos por
crímenes contra la humanidad pero eso es
tema para otro vídeo lo importante es
que durante la segunda guerra mundial
los partisanos consiguieron echar a los
nazis de la zona y estos partisanos de
ideología comunista tenían como líder a
este señor que veis en pantalla
josep bros más conocido como tito desde
el primer momento el mariscal tito tuvo
muy claro que su principal tarea era
ungir a los distintos grupos nacionales
en una yugoslavia moderna así que
reconoció sus derechos dando el estatus
de república a bosnia herzegovina
croacia eslovenia macedonia montenegro y
la propia serbia
en la antigua yugoslavia la presión
nacional por parte de la gran camarilla
capitalista serbia significó fortalecer
la explotación económica de los pueblos
oprimidos en la nueva llegó es la vía
socialista la igualdad de derechos
existente para todas las nacionalidades
ha hecho imposible que un grupo nacional
imponga la explotación económica a otro
yo así broz tito y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando como un país comunista a
yugoslavia seguro que era un satélite de
moscú verdad pues nada de eso yugoslavia
se había liberado por sí misma gracias a
la lucha de los partisanos de tito y
tito rechazaba cualquier intromisión de
moscú de hecho durante casi todo el
siglo 20 en los yugoslavos eran algo así
como los grandes afortunados del mundo
podían viajar y hacer negocios en todo
el planeta tanto en los países
capitalistas como los países comunistas
yugoslavia era una federación socialista
en la que cada república poseía su
propio parlamento y un alto nivel de
autonomía las decisiones que afectaban a
todo el país se tomaban de forma
conjunta a través de un consejo en el
que estaba un representante de cada
república la constitución yugoslava de
1974 aumentó la autonomía dentro de la
república de serbia de las provincias de
kosovo y de voivodina que pasaron a
tener representación en el consejo de
yugoslavia esto significaba que estas
provincias autónomas tenían el mismo
poder en yugoslavia que la propia serbia
pero esperado momento porque no todo es
tan bonito en el año 1980 'tito' murió y
yugoslavia entró en una crisis económica
brutal y eso incluye una hiperinflación
de niveles bolivarianos y claro cuando
las cosas van bien pues todos somos
amigos los serbios los croatas los
eslovenos los kosovares pero cuando las
cosas van mal crees que el gobernante de
turno solo intenta beneficiar a los
suyos y perjudicarte a ti
así que a finales de los años 80 cos
software un auténtico polvorín los
serbokosovares se sentían oprimidos por
la mayoría étnica de origen albanés es
decir los albano kosovares al frente de
kosovo y de su partido comunista estaban
los albano kosovares así que el
conflicto ya estaba en la calle para
calmar las cosas el partido comunista
serbio envió a su segundo de a bordo y
allí es donde aparece el gran
protagonista de nuestra historia
slobodan milósevic y en un mitin es
cuando los serbokosovares le dijeron oye
milósevic defiende nuestros derechos
porque los albanokosovares nos están
hostigando miranda
[Aplausos]
más opciones
y así miles de beats les escucho a
partir de entonces milasevic adoptó un
nacionalismo muy popular entre la
población serbia en 1989 se convirtió en
presidente de toda yugoslavia y una de
sus primeras medidas fue eliminar la
autonomía de las provincias de kosovo y
vojvodina haciéndose con sus votos en el
consejo que gobernaba yugoslavia a la
vista del poder que acumulaba el
nacionalismo serbio eslovenia y croacia
las repúblicas más ricas de yugoslavia
optaron por declarar su independencia y
así es como empezó la guerra de los
balcanes
[Música]
la guerra de yugoslavia
la primera república en independizarse
fue eslovenia en eslovenia vivían muy
pocos serbios así que realmente no hubo
grandes problemas por supuesto hubo una
guerra con yugoslavia pero seamos
francos duró solamente diez días sin
embargo el caso de los croatas fue muy
distinto porque croacia si tenía serbios
étnicos viviendo en su territorio así
que belgrado envió al ejército yugoslavo
para enfrentarse a los croatas la guerra
de la independencia croata duró años y
fue todo un baño de sangre pero ojo
porque no fue nada comparado con bosnia
[Música]
en este caso hablamos de tres bandos que
peleaban entre sí los bosniacos de
religión musulmana luchaban por
sobrevivir los otros azuzados por serbia
y croacia querían repartirse bosnia eran
los bosnio croatas católicos y los
serbobosnios cristianos ortodoxos los
serbobosnios llegaron a crear su propia
república independiente la república
srpska aquí es donde surgió el asedio a
sarajevo que seguramente os sonará a
muchos por los telediarios de vuestra
infancia en este momento es cuando la
onu decretó una zona de exclusión aérea
y quien defendía el espacio aéreo de
bosnia exacto la otan y eso explica que
en el año 1994 la otan de rivas y hasta
cuatro aviones serbobosnios y diréis y
que pensaba rusia al respecto pues lo
cierto es que a duras penas protestaron
pensando bien boris yeltsin el entonces
presidente de rusia acababa de
bombardear el mismísimo parlamento ruso
así que como os podéis imaginar tenía
otros asuntos que atender y eso explica
declaraciones como
el dilema de bosnia y el sinn advierte a
los serbios que detengan los ataques la
tajante declaración del líder del
kremlin muestra un cambio de actitud
hacia los aliados de toda la vida lo que
pasa es que los sorbo bosnios son unos
tipos más duros que la mantis de lobezno
no veían motivo alguno para parar la
guerra ni siquiera después de que los
bosniacos es decir los musulmanes y los
bosnio croatas católicos unieran sus
fuerzas contra ellos estaban ganando
pero en 1995 todo cambió
y croatas lograron el apoyo del ejército
croata los serbobosnios decidieron morir
matando y perpetraron entonces la
masacre de srbrenica el mayor genocidio
de la guerra de voz y como las cosas se
estaban poniendo muy pero que muy feas
la otan lanzó la famosa operación fuerza
deliberada una campaña aérea de tres
semanas que obligó a los serbobosnios a
negociar los rusos protestaron pero
entendieron que era la única forma de
acabar la guerra así que tampoco
protestaron demasiado incluso moscú
llegó a participar junto a occidente en
la negociación de los acuerdos de dayton
a por fin los balcanes respiraron
aliviados es verdad que no todos los
serbios dayton fue algo así como el
versalles serbio un acuerdo humillante
los serbobosnios rechazan el acuerdo de
dayton el tratado se vea amenazado pero
la historia no termina aquí la calma en
los balcanes duró hasta el año 1998
porque entonces es cuando empezó una
guerra de baja intensidad entre las
fuerzas yugoslavas y los albano
kosovares que todavía quedan
independizarse de serbia
occidente castigó a milósevic por su
represión en kosovo mediante sanciones
internacionales no surtieron efecto así
que la otan obligó a belgrado a negociar
para devolver a kosovo la autonomía pero
de nuevo milósevic rechazó la
participación de las tropas
internacionales y aquí es donde llegamos
a los famosos bombardeos de los que
hablaba vladimir putin su discurso en
este momento la otan se vio legitimado
para bombardear yugoslavia sin el
beneplácito de la onu duraron dos meses
y medio y fueron condenados por rusia al
final milósevic se rindió y kosovo se
convirtió en una especie de protectorado
de la onu con los años terminó
declarando su independencia con el visto
bueno de occidente algo utilizado por
putin para validar la anexión de crimen
[Música]
pero todo esto no es nada o van con esta
clasificación sobre el régimen de prisa
rust king crimson y creemos que el
trataron crowne hacia grecia caída
prospección por cierto de las fuerzas
rusas participaron en el contingente
internacional que ocupo kosovo pero iban
algo así como por libre de hecho a punto
estuvo de producirse el primer choque
armado entre rusia y la otan cuando los
rusos se adelantaron y tomaron el
aeropuerto de prístina en kosovo allí
hubo aún más que palabras pero
afortunadamente nadie disparó primero
desde entonces los balcanes han
aguantado en un frágil equilibrio de
fuerzas que podría desestabilizarse en
cualquier momento y más con lo que está
pasando ahora mismo en ucrania atentos
los amigos de rusia
[Música]
la invasión de crimea nos enseñó algo
que parecía imposible que los mapas de
europa pueden cambiar en cualquier
momento desde entonces serbia ha
aumentado su inversión en defensa en un
70 por ciento hasta alcanzar los mil 400
millones de dólares al año casualidad en
visual política sabemos que no esto es
como el parís saint germain en el fútbol
no te gastas una millonada para luego no
presumir de poderío
serbia acaba de encargar airbus 211 295
anteriormente negoció con ir en la
adquisición de misiles antitanque y con
turquía los drones a los que azerbayán
sacó tanto partido para derrotar a
armenia nagorno karabaj también ha
comprado drones de combate chinos
helicópteros rusos y un sistema francés
de misiles tierra-aire además en los
últimos años rusia bielorrusia le han
donado 10 cazas mig-29 y el kremlin
también le regaló 30 tanques y vehículos
blindados de transporte de personal al
tiempo que le vendía un sistema de
defensa aérea
a ver con esto no os penséis que
queremos decir mirad qué malos son los
serbios porque seamos claros eeuu
también le ha dado helicópteros
blackhawk a croacia lo que queremos es
reflejar que si durante dos décadas los
países que integraron la antigua
yugoslavia han intentado reconstruirse
algunos mejor que otros pero lo cierto
es que también se están rearmando y
serbia se está gastando más en su
ejército que albania bosnia montenegro
kosovo y macedonio del norte juntado
[Música]
por sí solo esto no tendría ningún
significado el pasado otoño por una
discrepancia menor puntos o el grado
envió aviones de guerra cerca de la
frontera y hasta desplegó vehículos
blindados para intimidar a lo que en su
día fue una antigua provincia pero
pensando las guerras del pasado resulta
más preocupante el auge del discurso
nacionalista dentro del propio gobierno
serbio escuchar sin ir más lejos a su
ministro del interior alexander bullying
en la llamada asamblea de todos los
serbios que se celebró a finales de mayo
las soluciones se crean un mundo serbio
son vistas con muchísimo recelo por
todos los países de la zona donde hay
una comunidad importante de serbios hay
muchísimo miedo a que esta idea de una
gran serbia provoque la vuelta de las
armas en cualquier caso hay que
diferenciar que una cosa es que serbia
no quiere imponer sanciones a la rusia
de putin o que incluso haya aprovechado
la situación para obtener un acuerdo de
suministro de gas ruso en condiciones
muy ventajosa y otra cosa muy diferente
es que serbia vaya a tomar la iniciativa
[Música]
pero sobre todo esto sobre la situación
actual de serbia sus relaciones con
rusia y también con la unión europea os
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo que
publicaremos muy pronto en visual
político estad atentos porque seguro que
son muchas las cosas que os van a
sorprender de este extraño país
balcánico
lo cierto es que oficialmente en
belgrado siguen queriendo entrar en la
unión europea y el país está
prácticamente rodeado por la otan salvo
por un lugar bosnia herzegovina un
estado federal en el que todavía hoy la
repubblica es ser pesca es una entidad
propia de bosnia hablaremos pronto aquí
en visual político porque os aseguro que
es un país muy especial es un país para
que os hagáis una idea que tiene tres
presidentes distintos y allí milorad
dodik el líder de los serbobosnios ha
elevado el tono amenaza con romper el
país y lo viene haciendo desde el pasado
otoño que se reunió con el ministro ruso
de exteriores ya que la reunión se
dieron informaciones de que los
serbobosnios habían pedido ayuda
armamentística a moscú escucha lo que
dice milorad dodik sobre la
independencia de las repúblicas
[Música]
y
europa sería una forma de desestabilizar
a occidente con rusia golpeada de forma
tan contundente por las acciones no
podemos descartar que el kremlin haya
puesto bosnia en su punto de mira
también es verdad que de toda esta
historia de cómo se desintegró la
antigua yugoslavia hay una auténtica
víctima que son los bosnios pero como ya
os he dicho de esto hablaremos en otro
vídeo porque ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que rusia está dispuesta
a reabrir viejas heridas de los balcanes
es posible que vuelva a estallar la
guerra en lo que en su día fue la
antigua yugoslavia podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual polític para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si se ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]